Let's get into it.
Our first question comes from Stephanie.
What is your question?
So my question is, I went on a date with a guy,
and he brought his dog with him,
but he didn't bring any food or water for the dog.
So is that like a red flag that he didn't bring
something to take care of his animal?
What kinda dog?
Like a little Doberman. A small little cute guy.
Like a mini-pin?
Yeah
I guess a small dog is like an accessory,
but if it was a Great Dane,
that's a thruple.
Right.
Yeah, yeah. Right.
Yeah.
Also, a straight man brought his dog on a first date?
Girl, uh-uh.
Maybe a sign.
And a mini-pin.
(Matteo laughing)
If he had brought the dog and crushed it.
Like, had been caring and nurturing,
and shown, like missed opportunity, I think,
to show that he is amazing
with the dog.
Mm-hmm.
I would feel two things
if a man showed up with a dog on a date.
One, I'd be like, "Oh, my god, so exciting!"
'Cause a dog, how cute, and then two,
no that's not gonna work in the relationship,
and I'll tell you why.
If that dog's getting in the way at lunch,
what's it gonna do when you get home?
You know what I'm saying?
Right.
That dog's in the bed,
now you talk about a thruple, hello.
(audience laughing)
So I think it's a red flag.
Mm-hmm.
Okay. All right.
Thank you, Stephanie.
Thank you.
Good luck!
(audience applauding)
Next up, Alton,
what is your question?
So my question
is, so I went on a couple dates with a girl,
and after the second date,
which was only about a week in,
she basically admitted
that she had really, really strong feelings for me,
and she was already ready to move on to something more.
Oh, gosh.
So, I definitely liked the girl,
but I was not ready to move so quick.
So my question is, how do I handle that,
without hurting anyone's feelings?
I always have the follow-ups. How old is she?
Like 23.
Oh, that's young.
Oh, yeah.
See, if she was older-
Tick-tock.
Right?
If she was older, I'd be like,
you know what?
She knows what she likes.
I appreciate the emotional vulnerability. That's-
I say call witness protection program.
(group laughing)
(audience laughing)
Mm-hmm. Well, yeah, Alton, here's the deal.
I think, which if she's going this fast,
girl, she doesn't even know who you are,
and so I feel like maybe she's creating
this fantasy version of you,
and will the reality ever live up to her fantasy?
I think it's doomed for disaster. Sorry
But how do you say "This is moving too fast",
without throwing the baby
out of the bath water?
Mm-hmm.
How do you say, "I'm still figuring myself out,
could we take time to figure that out together,
and slow it down a little bit"
without offending them, or worst, inviting games in,
'cause you deserve that after date two.
You deserve time.
(audience applauding)
Yeah.
Okay, finally, Devin on Twitter asked,
"On a first date, is it a red flag
if a guy starts talking
about how good he is at his job,
and how much money he makes?"
And "Is he trying to boost his confidence or impress me?"
Huh.
Panel discussion.
Mm.
(Ross laughing)
I guess it depends on the location.
If we're at an Applebee's,
don't boast about how much money you have
over an onion blossom.
(Ross laughing)
Right.
You know, it's tacky.
It's tacky to talk about money. Isn't it?
I mean, you can do it in subtle ways,
like "I'll pay for dinner",
or "Next time, can I take you to my favorite show?"
To at least let them know
that I have the money to support you,
should this go farther,
but to boast about your money, that's a huge red flag.
I think that was so well said, Matteo
I will take care of you.
I will wine and dine you,
but I don't need to be gauche,
and talk about my money at the table.
Yeah.
Also, what are you,
writing it down and sliding it across?
Like what is that conversation?
Yeah.
That'd be kind of hot.
(group laughing)
This is my 401k, it's hot.
Yes.
That sounds like a 4:00 AM type thing.
(group laughing)
I think it's two different things. Right?
I think the money thing does feel gauche to me.
Yeah.
But I think we should
all say, I think I'm good at my job.
Yeah.
And so talking
about your job and what you do,
feels like two different things.
I think there's a way to flex and say,
"This is what I do. This is what I'm passionate about.
I think I'm really good at it."
The money thing is where it gets iffy for me.
Yeah.
Okay, before we go,
we've got another Valentine's Day check-in
with our couple in the audience, Elizabeth and Chris.
Hello.
Hey.
And I heard you both are thrill seekers,
where you would like to take each other
on an adventurous first date.
Is this true?
Yeah.
Yeah. (chuckles)
We both found out
that we like to do dangerous, thrill-seeking things,
and we wanna go skydiving.
Yeah.
(Drew gasping)
I have to say, I'm totally like you.
I'm a thrill-seeker.
So this is really fun.
Yeah.
I'm so into this.
Well, maybe when they jump from the plane,
they'll fall in love.
Aw!
Oh!
(audience applauding)
Well, to set the romantic mood,
Fernweh Edition makes beautifully hand-poured,
environmentally friendly, soy wax candles,
and the entire audience
is gonna go home with a hundred dollar gift card.
Yeah!
(audience cheering)
All right, well thank you Matteo Lane,
and Gloria Calderon Kellet.
I so appreciate your wisdoms, and your humor,
and your thoughtfulness in having a little Drew and A,
Valentine's Day edition.
Thank you, so much.
Thank you!
(audience cheering)
(bright music)